welcome to Hannity today is day 35 of
the Democrats secret soviet-style
impeachment coup attempt although it's
really been their goal think about it
from the day that you we the people
elected Donald Trump is president
breaking just moments ago the Democratic
Party may be starting to fracture look
at this at least one Democratic
congressman now reportedly planning to
oppose his party's latest unfair which
will explain impeachment measure we'll
have a full report tonight from Capitol
Hill but first another day a secret
meeting secret hearing secret
transcripts a secret whistleblower non
whistleblower hearsay whistleblower all
because of a phone call between
President Trump and the president of
Ukraine but tonight let me just cut to
the chase here none of this really in
truth matters the fake whistleblowers
thoughts their feelings don't matter
anonymous sources don't matter witnesses
to the phone call they don't matter none
of this circus that Democrats are now
dragging the entire country through
matters because we have the actual
transcript it is public and it shows
zero none no misconduct whatsoever by
the president the transcript not only
exonerates the president but it clearly
features a President of the United
States upholding his sworn duty to
execute the laws of the United States
and investigate for an election and
appearance
so nothing the Democrats have supposedly
cared about for three years all of a
sudden matters by the way there was even
a court decision in Ukraine and that
found that their government interfered
in our 2016 elections in an effort to
help Hillary Rodham Clinton I thought
Democrats cared about foreign
interference in our elections according
to a very credible report from Politico
this January 11 2017
they went into specificity in detail how
Ukraine worked in concert with the DNC
in 2016 to smear Donald Trump and help
elect Hillary Clinton in other word
the DNC literally colluded with Ukraine
how ironic tell Clinton win and to hurt
Donald Trump now asking a country in
this case Ukraine to cooperate in an
investigation that's actually not a
crime it's not bribery not a misdemeanor
it's certainly not treason it's actually
the president's job to faithfully uphold
and execute the laws of the land that is
his oath that is his constitutional
obligation but the leader now of this
new witch-hunt we have the corrupt
compromised coward and congenital liar
Adam Schiff he wants you to believe
something much different Schiff who
won't come on this show to defend
himself that goes on every other show
has zero fidelity to truth he is a
pathetic liar and for three years he has
worshiped at the altar of his
impeachment lies its constant lies he's
got all the evidence we'd ever need
about Russia Russia Russia collusion it
was a hoax a conspiracy theory lies
didn't work out now let's try Ukraine
it's a evolving narrative they're now
calling it in other words you have the
coward ship trying really hard to get
his lies straight remember first
according to ship there were multiple
direct quid pro quos from the
president's call with the Ukrainian
president and the president released the
transcript that proved to be a lie to
that allegation and when Ukraine's
president and their foreign minister
both said they felt zero pressure
whatsoever well then there's chef he
claimed there was some kind of
behind-the-scenes effort then to shake
down Ukraine over time by withholding
aid but when we found out the money was
actually released without any conditions
whatsoever and that the Ukrainian
government didn't even know that the
money was delayed at the time of the
call Schiff had to change his narrative
again calling in witness after witness
but only behind closed doors without
real Republican due process at all to
speculate on the president's intentions
you know what you know who hasn't
testified interesting they're not
talking any more about the soap
whistle blower non whistle blower who
started the entire process now why is it
because shifts office we now know was in
contact apparently even advising him
from the very beginning Republicans we
ever get that guy under oath all they'll
be asking a lot of questions about that
and that guy's supported Joe Biden
they told him apparently according to
reports to get a lawyer they encouraged
him to file a complaint with the
Inspector General and that means Schiff
is a fact witness in the case he
blatantly lied about this coordination
as we proven on t v-- ship is
compromised
he's a fact witness in the case in which
he is now presiding
he should recuse himself he is
compromised corrupt a coward and a
congenital liar that's who's leading the
new witch-hunt so today when democrats
said they were alarmed they were alarmed
by the testimony of alexander binman a
national security expert i understand a
war hero thank you sir for serving our
country he was on the phone call
but the problem is keep in mind the
democrats interpretation of his
interpretation of the phone call but we
don't need his interpretation because we
have the transcript it doesn't matter
frankly with all due respect and I mean
that sincerely what he or anybody else
thinks it's all feigned outrage there
acting hour II Wow somebody else
interpreted it the sick way we do or the
corrupt way we do ok well that's their
interpretation but as a matter of law
even the Department of Justice
investigation concluded today no
collusion there was nothing wrong
nothing illegal about the president's
call but the corrupt Democrats they
could not care less
yeah I've shift yeah Pelosi they're now
ready for phase two of their impeachment
coup attempt and today they cooked up a
resolution I got it right here in front
of me it's not worth the paper that it's
printed on I wasted paper
I hurt trees in the process that would
make their cool proceedings public one
big catch would actually read the
document which I've done well there's
one huge massive gigantic caveat that
the compromise congenital liar Adam
Schiff and its fellow Democrats they
actually can veto any
public an attempt to call witnesses
subpoena evidence and pretty much
anything else they need the compromise
shifts approval for everything and maybe
that's why Nancy Pelosi is refusing to
call this an official impeachment
resolution take a look I guess
Pelosi and I can agree on one thing it's
not an impeachment resolution this is
not what Newt Gingrich offered Bill
Clinton in 1998 his process was actually
really fair she doesn't want a mirror
that what this is is smoke and mirrors
they're trying to make you think it is
something that it is not it is not fair
it is not what Newt Gingrich offered to
Clinton it's anything but fair now what
this really is is a massive fishing
expedition in the hopes that any cooked
up allegation might stick net will
impeach him we don't know one what but
they will impeach them then it is a
fraudulent it is an unconstitutional
show trial devoid of all due process it
is a legitimate it's an impeachment coup
attempt run by a corrupt compromise
congenital liar who's been hell-bent on
destroying the presidency of Donald
Trump regardless of truth logic common
sense reason and facts and now breaking
just moments ago at least one Democrat
apparently is breaking rank NBC News
reporting that New Jersey congressman
Jeff Andrew will likely vote against the
impeachment measure it's important to
note van drew is one of 31 Democrats
they represent districts who voted for
Donald Trump in 2016